there are now mass graves all over
northern ukraine filled with the bodies
of innocent civilians nearly 300 people
were just buried in one of those mass
graves outside of bucha russian soldiers
meanwhile reportedly squatted in the
homes of local residents for weeks
eating their food and getting
belligerently drunk on their liquor all
told the horror the inhumanity of this
occupation of putin's war has been
unimaginable south of keeve in the
besieged city of mario pole we go back
there the conditions get worse every day
almost every single solitary building in
the city has been torched or leveled by
russian shelling there's no power
there's no water there's no food there's
no supplies tens of thousands of
civilians are trapped completely cut off
from the world as russia's onslaught
continues some are killed by cluster
bombs others now die of starvation it's
an apo
apocalyptic scene with an extreme death
toll everywhere you look there is clear
indisputable evidence of war crimes make
no mistake this blood is on one man's
hands vladimir putin now these people
died all because of his territorial
ambitions that of a murdering dictator
thug and tonight the u.s can do a lot to
end this war can help drive russia out
of ukraine once and for all
again in spite of people lying about me
and saying oh hannity's calling for
american troops on the ground i am not
we don't need u.s troops on the ground
we don't need a no-fly zone but guess
what we can't get into a shooting war
and start world war three with putin's
russia but the byte administration the
ukrainian people have shown valor
courage bravery and a willingness to
fight for their own country and we can
play a critical role as can nato and
western european countries and take a
page out of the reagan doctrine instead
of sending him waves of u.s ground
troops to foreign lands in a long bloody
conventional war while reagan armed our
allies armed for example the mujahideen
not exactly our allies but he armed them
so they could fight for their own
freedom in their own country and they
did and they won and they defeated the
former soviet union in the 80s also
ronald reagan helped the nicaraguan
freedom fighters the contra rebels who
were fighting then against the
soviet-back easters
and they were successful in those
efforts biden can do the same exact
thing in conjunction with nato countries
and western european countries really
two things need to happen only two
according to my sources american and
western european weapons they are not
getting to ukraine fast enough now i do
blame our lethargic federal government
we need to see the urgency because they
are fighting this war in real time not
through some bureaucratic red tape and
slow leadership they need a constant
flow of stingers javelins drones
anti-missile anti-aircraft systems and
ammunition in the hands of the
ukrainians and they need it without
delay now you think about it it's a
nine-hour flight from washington dc to
poland that's it you can do it very
quickly number two our allies in europe
they need to stop funding the war and by
funding it i'm talking about countries
like germany many other western
countries they continue to purchase
massive amounts of oil and gas from
russia well guess what that money's
going right into putin's pocket and that
helps him fund this war and it's keeping
his economy afloat and we're talking
about billions of dollars every day we
can get our allies finally the energy
that they need guess what but we have to
be willing to produce it right here in
the united states and anywhere we can in
the interim and they have to be willing
to cut russia off once and for all how
much more carnage does europe and the
u.s need to see
you need to get ukraine the weapons they
need quit buying russian oil and gas
it's not really more complicated than
that if the free world can somehow
manage to do those two things
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
innocent lives will be saved hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else